pop
[Musique]
com
[Applaudissements]
au monde
[Musique]
à
mais
et
non
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
je
ah ah
[Musique]
flo
3 contre 1 la cote n'est pas fameuse
monsieur
[Musique]
merci la france et oui
[Applaudissements]
permettez moi de me présenter je vous
écoute par dont celui les dames où je
crois car ni le meilleur alors en ce cas
[Musique]
c'est fait tu rigoles bons auteurs
maintenant je présente martial 16h du
jardin des plantes de paille tu musée
greuze debout au fond monsieur mon nom
et au hamas trois grandes ya tenons
d'abord enlever s'est posé à très bien
très efficace un tueur monsieur walton
lesquels salle d'armes fréquentez-vous
au l'épaule et pont du navire
ah oui au pontet divine sans vos jeunes
gens pris ces messieurs désiré à aux
classes et que mon agent et je leur ai
dit non alors de fil en aiguille
heureusement que je passais par là oui
comme vous dites en france l'oignon fait
la farce d'en perdre l'union fait la
force
oui si vous voulez je what i drink
ah oui venez je vous en offrir oui avec
le beau gosse qui n'ont pas pris grâce à
la wii je suis venu à l'ombre merci pour
me renseigner sur les voiliers qui vont
aux indes watts vous avez l'intention
d'aller aux had oui oui enfin j'avais
oui je voulais capturer quelques tigres
du bengale pour notre muséum du jardin
des plantes de paris
unique au monde mais je crois je dois y
renoncer
oui le voyage est trop long six mois de
traversée les pauvres petites bêtes
crèvent en mal de mer vo thi goût
garderont une santé des les facois &
haas
j'ai une haute route pour une autre
route pour les indes que la route des
indes ya sein une nouvelle route
j'ai pensé à ceux la peau des mois une
révolution voulait sans doute dire une
révélation
non
un temple et changement voici la goutte
actuel de la fameuse compagnie d un
regarder les voiliers parts d'angleterre
elle contourne l'afrique par le cap de
bonne espérance et elle traverse l'océan
indien et si les moussons veulent bien
elle arrive à bambecque six mois plus
tard ce voyage les accomplissent cinq
fois depuis que j'étais 15 ans et chaque
fois sans année d'ennui et vous pensez
qu'il pourrait y avoir une autre route y
est deux fois plus rapide pour les vous
êtes assez gentil poursuivre mon doigt
moi je traverse laura la méditerranée
les gîtes suez la mer rouge
et là je suis à mambé mais c'est la
route des épices aux moyennes à juste
mais avec une nouveau chose qui change
tout la vapeur navigation la vapeur la
vie ah oui ces fameux bateau à charbon
et oui mais ils ne peuvent s'effectuer
que de petits trajets sur les mers
comment comment pourrait-il se
ravitailler en combustible wayne sur la
mer où c'est possible à cause du grand
nombre de les escales d'ailleurs un
premier steam venons de bambins doit
arriver à suez le 8 décembre et ses sept
nains viola retournons que je prendrai
un suez pour gagner bandai ainsi je
prouverai que ma route est celle de
l'avenir parce qu'elle est de beaucoup
la plus rapide
je pense environ trois mois au lieu de
six mois par la route du cap ja seule la
moitié du temps et pour que ma
démonstration ne soit pas discuter je
ferais l'aller et au retour
londres bombay l'ombre en moins de six
mois
attendez
je comprenne bien vous voulez aller au
sein dé revenir en moins de temps que
mettent les voiliers du cap simplement
pour y aller voilà owens évidemment aux
vapeurs de la mer rouge
fantastique alors comme ça mais tigre
supporterait le voyage et arriverait
vivant à paris mon cher tom
pensez vous qu'il y est une place pour
moi sur votre fameux vapeur venez avec
moi suez et je vous en trouverez une
place vendue lui mais dites moi nous
sommes le 25 octobre et votre vapeur par
de suez lui descendre alors qu'est-ce
qu'on attend vont partir
la bénédiction de la toute puissante
compagnie des indes et safin ancien aide
car notre voyage va quand même très cher
martiale mais la compagnie sur incident
hui je suis sur ma route à une si grande
à venir et quand pensez-vous obtenir
l'accord de la compagnie mais demain je
dois rencontrer tous les directeurs pour
leur exposer mon projet
[Musique]
non
voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors john malone iphone tandis que la
frégate la mode et il y aura quatre
hommes de nationalité n'est pas malade
giovanni thank you happy end
même constat
certes sommes au directeur de la
compagnie des indes me semble des
conservateurs accroché à la seconde
village ils veulent bien profiter des
indes mais sans prendre le moindre
risque
les chemins de l'europe leur font
toujours peur gamme pause ils sont des
idiots
kouakou renonceriez moi jamais je suis
plus têtu qu'une mule des cornouailles
et moi canal dubois toi oui mais reste
la question de l'argent nécessaire au
voyage
je vais proposer un investissement un
mes amis tu as été bon quand croyez moi
la nouvelle vous des halles sera amené à
rythme lent et peut-être aussi pour vous
de quelques embûches pas de cause
comme elle mais 76 ou face aux jo a même
sonné eagles
bonjour monsieur karam est le projet de
travaux soient grandes banques est
repoussé par la cour des directeurs à
bonne nouvelle oui mais il parle quand
même pour faire sa démonstration à il
parle quand même mieux que ça il a
annoncé qu'il ferait l'aller-retour
londres rome et londres en moins de six
mois quoi en moins de six mois
impossible maintenant je vais vous dire
quelque chose moi monsieur webb va
peut-être partir mais il verra sûrement
pas loin
hasting m bonsoir j'ai une affaire à
vous proposez vous tombait à pic a
carrément donné par ici
non continuer à jouer je vais ajouter 10
dont c'est pas l'armateur qui est avec
lui si si tu le veux encore violent et
joseph pièce je suis renseigné sur ce
tome ce wagon il est courageux donc
dangereux un dangereux pour qu'ils lui
pour vous pour moi comme pour tous ceux
qui ont bâti leur fortune sur la route
du cap
je suis vous le savez le plus gros
armateurs de la ligne pour voiliers sur
quatre m'appartiennent le wagon
réussisse son voyage par l'intérieur et
plus personne n'ira aux indes par la
cale ce serait donc lui n'est ce qui
signifie que vous êtes prêts à mettre
beaucoup d'argent
oui beaucoup pour 400 me soit gong se
casse les reins sur sa route du diable
j'ai besoin donc de l'homme capable du
pire si la situation exige tout à fait
vous n'est ce pas vous flattez beaucoup
mais sûr que ramos nos je vous offre
deux mille livres sterling faut saboter
l'entreprise de ces géniales mbissine il
va falloir le retarder par tous les
moyens
tout le long de saout il prétend mettre
six mois pour aller aux seins nus en
revenir
il en mettra au moins le double si
toutefois il arrive à bombay faites moi
confiance
oui mais attention si malgré tout while
on devait arriver à bombay en moins de
trois mois
1 alors écoutez s'ils devaient y arriver
il ne repartirait pas et il n'y aurait
pas de retour pour lui et à bombay
il aurait droit à une jeune tombe mais
au fond il serait peut-être plus simple
que je supprime tout de suite face à
thomasg ans non non pas tout de suite ce
serait dangereux
je sais prédit à faire ça vous savez la
compagnie des indes s'étant opposé au
son projet on pourrait l'accuser d'avoir
inspiré le meurtre et je ne veux causait
aucun ennui à la compagnie des indes
eh bien on va s'en occuper tout de suite
ce monsieur varone
ou est-ce qu'on peut le trouver à son
quartier général une célèbre taverne du
port d indian mère facile à retenir est
ce pas la malle des indes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un tas de soie et mailles 13,1 par dean
to die de globex presque en ligue 1 dont
deux fillettes interview que picard
meschers road again we were going
anywhere une incontinence payet
[Applaudissements]
les manifestants comptent mener au score
mais bélie 2 tonnes andrew wylie merci
martial jinyi semaine ma plus tendre
actionnaires
1 3 qui nice et combien battements de
coeur autant que moi
touring any two and your name ça world à
tom de sanguinet d'un généreux donateur
merci monsieur guy et moi un penny
pour john et là c'est tout ce que je
mise sur votre pari stupide amazon vous
allez mettre 2 ans voit arriver à bombay
par votre route du diable et tous vos
amis seront ruinés vous voyez je vous
dis ça en français vous ménager pour les
gars de monsieur il ya des oreilles
françaises pour vous entendre
ah parce que monsieur fait peut-être
aussi ce voyage oui monsieur g cet
honneur et bien messieurs
un conseil d'ami vous feriez mieux de
renoncer tous les deux parce que je
voudrais dire deux pauses en niveau 6
est une menace elle nous laisse froid et
conseils pour conseil feriez mieux de
vider les lieux
et bien tant pis vous aurez été prévu
une paille
j'ai l'impression qu'on s'intéresse déjà
beaucoup pas nous et oui mais ça prouve
la valeur de mon idée un incident vous
persistez dans votre projet vous avez
fondé votre porte compagnie oui
globex presque envie et qu'on pense
avoue partir tous les deux je regagne la
france aujourd'hui même pour régler
quelques affaires et pour moi je
quitterais manhattan ville de chatham le
28 octobre
nous nous retrouverons près de paris et
prendrons ensemble la route du sud
je ne veux pas jouer les oiseaux de
mauvais augure moi je dois vous dire que
je n'ai pu mauvaises nouvelles de france
charles dussault s'ils se sentent rome
et la révolution menace mais ne
passeront entre les guillotines monsieur
le président vous êtes lui-même imputant
cela dit monsieur wagon je ne peux rien
pour s'y met c'est le président vous
pouvez beaucoup on me délivrons un
document attestant sous votre signature
la date de notre départ pour les apps
je vous vois venir mais ce wagon notre
voilier du cap est parti il ya huit
jours
et comme vous êtes sûrs d'arriver aux
arènes avant lui
vous vous rendrez à bombay ce document
vous le démontrer que votre route est la
meilleure c'est bon vous avez grande
cause monsieur l'obstiné en somme
thomson par le sceau de la compagnie des
zincs départ le 28 octobre
c'est déjà à moitié gagné mais attendez
d'avoir le bel en france est partie je
vous dis tout cas vous vous êtes déjà
parti je vous souhaite un bon voyage
mais aussi bien ou puis je vous ai posé
e
je dois m'occuper de mon passeport et
c'est à côté à bientôt
my friend à n'oublier pas top je vous
attends rené du coq d'argent vingt lieux
avant paris br j sur comme ça je vais
pouvoir annoncer au bar au cuvier que
grâce à vous il aura ses tigres du
bengale pour son musée où il va frétille
comenius
à bientôt et bible aventure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes sûr que cette france et
part avec vagues rendent absolument sur
une assise aux cars ils sont les ventes
et alors il faudra que vous vous
occupiez de lui aussi compter sur nos
yeux car amos le français sera soigné
comme l'anglais quand même mais cet
homme semble s'y opposer
handy exclu excusez moi qu'est ce qui se
passe est bien trop mou soit grande sort
de la compagnie 10,1 quoi oui le
président de via signer un document
attestant son départ pour bombay c'est
pour le 28 octobre
vous avez entendu monsieur taylor 3mos
wagons par le 28 octobre
eh bien moi je sais maintenant je
quitterais l'angleterre le 28 octobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
jean marie robine bombay pas aimer fun
and her way fois de plus avec space
company
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
pardon monsieur ries
savez vous où par la diligence propre à
l'hôtel de londres place de france vous
n'avez qu'à me suivre
j'y vais pour pardon je ne me suis pas
présentée félix botrel voyageur de
commerce pour vous servir montre de
gousset tabatière carte à jouer
dentelles d'arras et dessous féminins
heureuse de vous rencontrer monsieur
beaudoin directeur de la grande collecte
quoi allons voir cette diligence des
messageries du royal vive le roi vous
voyez je ne cache pas les opinions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ils se sont battus si vous n'appelez pas
appris la nouvelle aux pauvres il ya
quasiment eu la révolution ouvriers ont
attaqué les boulangeries les gendarmes
ont chargé à cheval heureusement ce nom
la canaille l'emportait et vive le roi
sans dieu gagnent ça vous dit
dieu sauf vaud 3 a très bien alors là
vous vous plaisez vous inquiète ce sont
des prisonniers et riz sont des forçats
qu'on embarque pour le bagne
rincez
[Applaudissements]
que fait ce monsieur et vous plaît
monsieur merci merci hongrie pourquoi
c'est la coutume à boulogne enquête pour
les prisonniers qui traverse la ville
un must have à nous y voilà l'at-elle de
long j'en serais pas là qu'est-ce qui se
passe oui la diligence le service vient
d'être suspendu par hors de la police et
l'hôtel est fermé et on trouvera aucun
cheval dans boulogne depuis l'émeute
nord-ouest
c'est vraiment très très d'infortuné je
dois absolument partir de ma soirée une
rendez vous très important près de barr
venez avec moi
merci
et vous en trouvez un cheval moi je
trouve toujours tout a vraiment dans le
quartier de la citadelle il ya une
petite taverne d'aléas peut voir ça et
fils angeli et le vin est bon mais mon
cheval s'est plaint de mal à la banque
qui se fera un plaisir de vous en
dénicher moyennant finance bien sûr oui
[Applaudissements]
moi on se marre messieurs mais seigneur
que puis-je avoir l'honneur de vous
servir et piano men m'a dit que je
pourrais trouver ici des vendeurs de
cheval euronews je crois que vous pouvez
faire à faire mais vous allez bien à
côté de mon sens il est excellent et
thierry des meilleurs fut alors un grand
péché oui
alors
et vous les mademoiselle k les bois un
peu de quoi rêver aussi l'anglais et
toitures y at il entre en bois
asseyez-vous merci vous vous êtes maturi
oui oui monsieur
rose-marie très joli et bien elles sont
mignonnes prévu et me voilà depuis jeu
et apporter un poiret et un sirop de
framboise au quad à boire et joyeusement
dans un danger là qui est ce broadhurst
a vraiment je vous préviens les
voyageurs il aime ça les voyageurs
encore il a des trous slam étrangers qui
veulent acheter à cheval à cheval ils
étrangers on n'a pas revu
oh oui à mon avis il est au fond de la
mer avec une pierre au cou sûrement dit
qu'en fait vous entendez ça et on
devrait s'en aller ce serait plus
prudent
tota bons joueurs sa typo des chevaux
cherché non merci on n'a pas du tout
besoin de chevaux bon à ces gens
cherchent à avant de marchander faut que
je voie l'artichaut et j'ai peur de ne
pas être venu avec ma fortune serment ah
oui on va voir ça
[Musique]
j'attends d'elle
boeing
[Musique]
non
la gauche anglais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
k
[Musique]
et maintenant alors je fais pas l'idiot
tu as joué tu as perdu embarquée et vous
qu'est ce que vous faites là haut
j'essaie d'aller aux ânes mais je
n'avais pas à sortir de votre salle wihr
je serai pas plutôt les filles de
boulogne qui vous dira tiens grève on
s'est toujours vivant et bien qu'il
donne c'est elle qui vous a sauvé la vie
messieurs les anglais ont patrouillé
dans la rue elle nous a alertés à c'est
bien ça merci au revoir au revoir
vous avez vous au moins vous trouvez un
livre je sois là non ne vous inquiétez
pas pour lire mona petit but
merci
qu'est ce qui se passe je vois
bonjour là bas fermé la rue que personne
ne passe coup faris vers la fin qu'est
ce qui se passe et deux forçats qu'on
embarque et qui se sont échappés un thon
rouge qui pour lui c'est fini
l'audois poids et ont commencé à
chercher dans les maisons la regarde
je crois bien que j'ai vue c'est toi qui
chantes tu es là je vous en prie ouvrez
ouvrez pour l'amour du ciel qui sait le
fossat qui sont en train de chercher
sûrement est ce qu'on fait c'est
dangereux et l' écoute les gens là ils
vont regarder là aussi au fond du
couloir gendarmerie royale ouvrait à
l'eau ou vrai mais qu'est ce qu'il y a
un grand un bagnard s'est échappé ah oui
on a entendu mais bon tout bagnole
il est pas là on va quand même regarder
et excusez moi le petit d'homme
e
bon c'est vu allez bonne nuit bonne nuit
merci je ne vous oublierai jamais tous
les deux
mon nom et veyran je ne suis pas un
malfaiteur
je n'ai tué personne j'ai été victime
d'une erreur judiciaire
et si je me suis évadé c'est pour faire
éclater mon innocence
vous allez pouvoir
oui mais il faut que je retrouve un
témoin et pour ça il faut que je puisse
quitter boulogne semble faire prendre je
vous ai assez ennuyé comme ça merci
encore mais attendez attendez je vais
donner un regard d'or
déshabillez vous connais mieux de
l'envoyer au cimetière tout de suite
dans les offres de taylor sont claires
ou comment sait on seulement après on
verra
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que vous
voulez excusez nous c'est une erreur on
est tombé merci bien soit vous j'ai
passé un mauvais quart d'heure
je vous devais bien ça maintenant
écouter les hommes tous les deux si j'ai
bien compris ou des filets en douce de
boulogne
mais ces jours ci c'est pas facile
j'ai dit dès demain matin
j'ai retrouvé un de mes amis qui ne peut
rien leur refuser
ayant senti que moderne sam et son désir
on sait leur ménage ces messieurs désire
retrouver un bagnard évadés rien à voir
non c'est pas lui c'est bon à ces lieux
on va bien mon ami très bien à la santé
de rosemary à les rebelles ou trois
liens
salut salut et marcello s'allier à toi
oui un compatriote un parisien ils sont
bloqués à boulogne je les amène jusqu'à
la route damien tu fais toujours le
mensonge
oui toujours allez au revoir et bonne
route à l'est
[Musique]
voilà moi j'ai continué à la la c'est la
route pour paris vous n'aurez pas de mal
à trouver une voiture les affaires je ne
sais pas comment il est parti c'était la
moindre
[Musique]
tiens
[Applaudissements]
te dis arrêtez moi là tu es sûr que tu
ne veux pas continuer avec nous jusqu'à
maintenant c'est trop dangereux pour
vous je m'arrangeais pour trouver une
autre voiture tu veux tiens des
provisions merci merci beaucoup
comme je ne vous oublierai pas dieu vous
bénisse
merci
[Musique]
voilà
mais
je reconnais
[Musique]
mais dont quelques points 3 passes ont
la peur et bien voici arrivés à amiens
merci vous voyez que c'est la diligence
po paris pour sûr que tu fais dit ça me
semble pas la révolution ici et amiens
et royalistes enfin encore aujourd'hui
allez bon voyage
merci encore et embrassés pour
malheureusement non monsieur quand par
la diligence pour paris dans un petit
quart d'heure alors gelé tant le plan
monté turquie au vous êtes sûrement
anglais comment avez vous deviné ayasse
et semblait pouvoir de laujol et ben haj
et vous la langue est et je suis à votre
pied excusez moi monsieur je me présente
barbara mètres du col profondément non
monsieur je voulais vous dire vous avez
tord de clamer plus de 700 blaise
c'est plein de policiers il faut achat
sur les publics aux étrangers toujours
soupçonnée de les aider salut la
dernière moi c'en est un plus
spécialement taillé même déguisé en
bourgeois on les repère immédiatement
enfin la république balaiera bientôt
tout ça un récit était tout ce qu'il ya
dans l'est monsieur l'anglais tranquille
mais sur l'aubergiste toujours le pen
passera pouvait pas faire un peu
attention si tu es moins chef a recensé
pour vous parler et bien par l'ibpt à
travailler j'en tiens un quoi un
étranger et avec ça c'est un anglais et
comment est-il c'est en anglais suspect
monsieur l'inspecteur tracey je vais
vous parler avec barbara bach par m le
maître d'école qui est sur nos listes et
un dangereux république eh bien nous
allons surveiller de près ses d'anglais
vous voyez mon petit vacherin que mon
idée de se mêler aux foules étaient
excellents arrêts vérité tout le monde
parlera bientôt de mon frère et je serai
plus célèbre que sue villoch vino
comment s'appelle-t-il vidocq
c'est l'inspecteur ah oui c'est sa vie
des auditons machin avez vous une petite
idée de ses projets à cet angle il va
prendre la diligence pour paris et bien
la prendre avec lui au génial monsieur
l'inspecteur
[Musique]
comme martial fidèle au rendez vous
enfin mon ami vous êtes là avec tous ces
événements j'ai cru que je n'arrive pour
m'avait promis des aventures sur le sol
français
et bien c'est fait aller raconter moi ça
bon écoutez moi bien vacherin l'anglais
vient de retrouver un complice alors
curé vous la trompe d'eustache aqua
l'oreille parce qu'il va falloir
attendre attendre quoi nous irons
[Musique]
m
cette fois on me dira un rhume et façade
avant s'est passé pour moi hrivik
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le cas avec notre carrière nous
sortîmes cska et on peut même pas de les
annoncer
taylor qui nous attend demain avec ton
ami de paris et à paris on n'y est pas
encore 6-6 lagarde a et avec ça nous
arriverons à vendre la diligence et
moins qu'habituellement les ferrures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bruit et la partons dans cinq minutes
nous arrivons à paris demain matin à 8
heures tu peux y est votre attention
s'il vous plaît bonsoir messieurs et
mesdames permettez-moi d'abord de me
présenter genre bastié du parc comédiens
de voler ma femme mais y ont fait très
enfants la plupart de moi j'ai parfois
des finances dans un état délicat ce qui
vous expliquent le rôle de conseillers
que je me propose de jouer pour vous
al'approche de pâques
je me permettrai donc devoir commander
dans notre capitale quelques hôtels
garnier maison de confiance propre et
honnête au service discret le service
bien fait et si vous le voulez je suis à
votre disposition aussi pour vous servir
de guide dans notre mystérieux mais
terrifiant paris où l'on côtoie la
misère et la richesse le vice et la
vertu
puis je vous rencontrerai à paris des
fourbisseurs des voleurs à la tire des
tire laine des escarres pas la cambriole
mais vous trouverez aussi 13 théâtre 300
fiac et huit cabinets d'aisance et aussi
320 fabricant de pianos
et en route messieurs dames s'activent
vous avez pu entendre ce qu'ils se
disaient pour le repas vers les ans
comme chef en coach et encode encore oui
il y avait un mot qui revenait souvent
j'ai pas très bien compris c'est cela
suppose non c'est suis en suisse
donc si je crois avoir entendu le
français dira l'anglais rendez vous au 6
de la rue de m'enseigner à paris dont
j'ai aussi chez les saint simoniens et
je suis presque sûr que le français des
textuellement à l'anglais votre
entreprise les intéressera sûrement
alors là c'est clair si ces terroristes
de saint simoniens son bébé à la fête
c'est un complot contre la sûreté de
l'état
royer géant messieurs bonsoir vergy a
les attendait et on vient aussi en 1829
à bord de voiliers qui contourne
l'afrique par le cap de bonne espérance
il faut six mois pour aller de londres à
bombay un jeune lieutenant de la marine
anglaise à l'idée d'une nouvelle route
des indes passant par l'europe la
méditerranée l'egypte
et l'océan indien il a calculé qu'en
utilisant le vapeur enterprises qui doit
être mise en service sur la mer rouge
il ne faudrait que trois mois par ce
chemin des terres pour gagner bombay ce
voyageur food aventure c'est un mas
waghorn pour démontrer à la face du
monde la supériorité de sa route il part
de londres un matin d'octobre en
compagnie d'un jeune naturaliste
français martial sassenage qui rêve lui
de capturer des tigres au bengale pour
la ménagerie du muséum d'histoire
naturelle de paris mais un riche
armateur de la ligne du cap craignant
d'être ruinés sitom réussi sa
démonstration va lancé contre lui un
redoutable gredins taylor
flanqué de deux arsouille bartolo et
joseph taylor a pour mission d'empêcher
par tous les moyens
les deux voyageurs d'arriver à bombay
malgré ces menaces qui pèsent sur eux
tom et martial débarque en france alors
que couvre la révolution de 1830 sur la
route de paris
ils sont repérés par deux agents de la
sûreté les inspecteurs fontanier et
vacherin qui les prennent pour des
espions dans une auberge proche de la
capitale
tom et martial font la connaissance d'un
comédien famélique vaste y ait du parc
qui s'offrent à leur servir de guide
dans le paris des plaisirs
[Musique]
bienvenue à paris sud et à votre bon
coeur
merci messieurs au pardon mon père et
fils voir le chef de la sûreté vous
suivez les deux individus et voyez où il
s'installe à paris bien monsieur
l'inspecteur dit dites moi si vous
voulez j'aurai deux charmantes camarades
à vous présenter un très très jolie
femme alors on pourrait se retrouver
vers midi au café de la retourne au
palais royal
ça vous ne regretterez pas de place dit
moi qu'est ce que tu penses martial
pourquoi pas ah oui mais avant avant à
quelle heure par la diligence pour lyon
euros seulement ce soir à 10h du tampon
2 1
d'accord pour lé petit gamin merci
monsieur g à votre service et tout à
l'heure midi à la rotonde e et sûrement
allez venez à mon pied-à-terre rue des
petits champs c'est pas loin
dites nous avons en policeman après you
vous à cannes et amiens instituteur me
laver signalisés il était aussi dans la
délivrance est maintenant et les cieux
long et allemands notamment
peut-être parce que je suis anglais pour
qu'on puisse sûrement oui en tout cas
comme vous n'êtes pas un espion et la
perdre son temps alors c'est fait
monsieur ils ont été au rendez-vous et
et deux filles
ils seront café de la rotonde à midi
parfait l'amour fait toujours perdre un
temps fou
ces messieurs avançons à pas recevoir
j'ai eu quelques petites frêche
[Musique]
voilà mon bon monsieur
et soyez à l'heure à la ronde notre plan
va se jouer à la minute
[Musique]
vous m'apprenez là monsieur fontanier
est très inquiétant et renforce mes
appréhensions il républicain les
libéraux relève la tête
ils recrutent chez les ouvriers et chez
les étudiants les sociétés secrètes se
multiplient l'opposition exploite les
difficultés économiques pour un oui ou
pour un non on manifeste on pille les
boulangeries aux menaces les percepteurs
et bien entendu la presse fait chorus le
seul chef de la sûreté
il faut sévir et bien sûr mais quand je
les conseillers l'autre jour à monsieur
de produits niaque qui entre nous sera
président du conseil dans quelques jours
savez vous ce qu'il m'a répondu mais
vous dramatisez qu'elle est guérie
non on voit bien que monsieur de
polignac ne va pas souvent dans les
foires à fontanier s'il était né avec
des serviteurs de votre qualité
perspicace lucide objectif et je dirais
même scientifique directeur est reporté
en tout cas cette affaire est sérieuse
montanier mais que va faire cet anglais
ce soir c'est les saint simoniens ces
fous qui croient au progrès social
c'est révolutionnaire qui veulent
supprimer l'héritage c'est dépravée qui
réclament l'égalité de l'homme n'a pas
de l'égalité de l'homme et de la femme
parfaite c'est drôle non va se reporter
nier ta parole ne s'est pas drôle on
commence par sourire de ses
extravagances et en finis et par
guillotine et le roy we grave très grave
bretagne et je comprends tout j'ai fait
décrypter le dialogue côté de vous deux
suspects peu et bien suis c'est suez et
suez égalé j -pd egypte et nos services
nous apprennent que suez est une ville
d'égypte alors ça c'est une mine alors
c'est clair
votre anglais est très probablement un
espion qui a pour mission de faire
échouer notre projet pour la conquête de
l'algérie avec l'appui de l'egypte
fontanier faut agir
oui monsieur directeur je vous donne
tous pouvoirs pour neutraliser cet agent
britannique avon le sécuritaire
facture encore des factures toujours des
factures et oui mon cher thot ça aussi
c'est paris des factures et martial vous
avez de la visite
si elle le poète ou la terrible c'est un
romantique
alors il va nous lire son dernier poème
en versant des torrent d'armes à mais
attendez il va au moins nous servir à
quelque chose
c'est un saint simoniens montserrat le
font entrer comme d'habitude par la
fenêtre au monsieur sassenage vous êtes
de retour auquel joie je voudrais vous
et merci moi d'abord sur voisins alors
voilà j'attends de vous un grand service
c'est chose faite
oui merci beaucoup voilà je souhaite que
vous présentiez ce soir au saint
simoniens un ami anglais
monsieur thomas souabe bonjour 13 e reçu
voilà monsieur waghorn seront aux indes
et son voyage va faire révolution alors
j'aimerais que vous préveniez le père
enfantin de notre visite
et puis depuis que monsieur wague en
fera un exposé de son entreprise
oui le père enfantin bonheur de son ami
tué mais c'est pourquoi j'ai pensé à
vous bon alors je cours chez lui c'est
ça au revoir monsieur a et surtout
n'oubliez pas à la réunion des saint
simoniens à 8 heures précises ne seront
pas en retard à ce soir on cherche on
dit moi martial ce père enfantin qui est
le chef des saint-simoniens d'où
vient-il
c'est un ingénieur est aussi un grand
philosophe mais il préconise le
collectivisme qui assurera chacun un
revenu selon ses oeuvres à ces trois
nouveaux arrêts et il prône aussi
l'amour libre
oh je sens que je deviens saint
simoniens mais il faut d'abord que vous
deveniez parisien mon cher tom a ni
choisir un costume dans ma garde-robe 1
vous étiez un gentleman nous allons
faire de vous un dandy
[Musique]
si les halles sont le ventre de paris
le café de la rotonde en est le nombril
joli nom win mais je ne vois pas notre
père de famille à défaut de notre libre
us nous pourrons voir quelques
célébrités bon costume vous pas très
bien tom peut-être un peu trop non plus
tôt pas assez regardez ces lamartine
notre byron lee passage à paris ah ben
voilà
et oui hé hé hé avec les deux beautés
promise
mademoiselle d'origine et mademoiselle
aldo elles jouent toutes ces deux
variétés une pièce de bonnes choses ce
crime
oui mazel rien qu'à vous voir mon ami
anglais applaudi les gens un angle
également aux as mais oui il y en a un
et spa martiale ont certainement garçons
jean bart
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur tout est en place
ces dames sont là tenez vous prêts et
ouvrez l'oeil un rendez vous au lieu
convenu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
venez déjeuner chez nous au oui oui
venez j'adore ça ne dit pas d'accord
mais tu sais j'ai un spa de l'eau à vous
venez avec nous sont chères baissier du
par non non non je dois vous pouvez vous
savez ma petite famille m'attend
trahison très bien mais moi voilà
monsieur sommes presque arrivés bien
dire maintenant parce que vous êtes
membre ou sociales et méfiante avec les
étrangers et pourquoi ça
[Musique]
tout a bien marché
et bien messieurs est maintenant le
deuxième acte
[Musique]
ça va mieux à ma chérie oui oui juste un
peu mal à la tête
savait pas par hasard cette voiture
probablement on fait tout pour nous
délayé délié a dîné retardé oui mais là
ça ne sert à rien tu verras j'ai appris
l'accident
oui la pauvre chérie j'ai amené un
médecin merci à le prêt de 6 ont tous
les leviers l'entrée de père mais je
crois qu'on ne sera pas trop grave
oh oh ma pauvre petit puis je ne sais
pas grave on gueule vous est entièrement
et comment avez vous été prévenue de
comment j'ai été premier bassin c'est
parce que j'étais dans j'étais noir une
seconde je te dire enfin je me suis
précipitée amis allaient tollé de la
merde leurs impôts qui se juge à
l'éprouvette
la voiture de ces messieurs et avant c
est pas un jeu wii oui ça va de soi oui
et encore merci monsieur bastié du
parent nommage viewed as je suis navré
mais la vie est tellement dur et puis
avec mes treize enfants qu est ce qu un
alors
vous allez voir si vous avez très bien
là aujourd hui
et puis vous savez tant que personne ne
viendra vous de l'enlever or c'est
vraiment gentil à vous de me faire fois
les catacombes
on avait tellement parlé avant
[Musique]
il faudra remercie monsieur veste et du
pad c'est lui qui nous avons seul
endroit au ménoni manqueront pas soit il
a assuré des columérins c'est pas demain
la veille allait avancer ma mère ici
commence lempire de la mort
[Musique]
ça donne à réfléchir
vous entendez lecteur tourne pas allez
messieurs la visite continue
vous allez dors et déjà perdu la partie
beaucoup d'eau aura coulé sous les
troncs de la famille avant qu on vous
retrouve ici
si vous n'avez jamais aux absa certains
noms dans plus de six mois autant pour
vous le français puisque vous
accompagnez monsieur sachez monsieur que
j'ai pour vous un mépris d'une
profondeur insondable par sd est alors
allé aux autres on va hausser sa vie aux
signaux êtes sûr que c'est la chef je
sais ce que je fais arrêter de dire des
bêtises et ouvrez l'oeil
le louvre chef
le regard tout même pas rentré chez les
saint simoniens ce qu'on les voit un
possible chef avec votre oeil the lines
[Applaudissements]
pardon messieurs la réunion des saint
simoniens est terminé merci messieurs la
diligence pour lui en est à 10 heures
ils vont peut-être apprendre il faut y
aller avant on y va je vous en prie non
c'est pas drôle
notez vous parce que je vais avoir des
cochons
je dois revoir les petites amies à la
route sentimentale beaucoup trop chargé
[Musique]
k
à
[Musique]
car
il dit
j'en ai
p
rires
partez
[Musique]
l'entente vous êtes ici vous avez été
attaqués mauvaise plaisanterie
moralement c'est une mauvaise
plaisanterie oui mais vous qui êtes vous
les étudiants en médecine on vient faire
la récolte
la récolte de quoi as tu bien venus
l'humérus à music matière première de
nos études à vous avez raison c'est une
vraie mini 6 annonce et a perdu on ne
doit pas toucher aux squelettes fera pas
de dire non non non vous inquiétez pas
nous on n'a rien vu absolument a en tout
ce qu'on voudrait c'est sortir ni scié
allez venez on voit compagne merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
10h15 notre petit détour dans les
catacombes nous a fait manquer tout la
réunion des saint simoniens est terminée
et la diligence pour lyon est parti j'ai
une solution
je vous trouve une voiture de postes
nous gagnons chalon le plus vite
possible et si nous réussissons à
attraper le vapeur sur la saône nous
serons à lyon avant la diligence mais
c'est superbe
oui oui mais avant avant je vais vous
demander la permission d'aller remercier
monsieur bastié du parc
le contraire serait impoli mais où
allons-nous trouvait là sur son terrain
de chasse
le café de la rotonde faites moi
confiance noisette faites moi confiance
non c'est vraiment donné deux jeunes
filles comme vous gagner un peu d'argent
et s'en sort miner la santé je me fait
toujours un devoir de les aider vous
savez le connecteur solitaire dans paris
qui ne savent pas bien de leur soirée
[Musique]
mon cher aussi du parc votre pourboire
pour la visite des catacombes
le voici moiselle l'église
c'est un de vos amis bastié voilà enfin
clients généreux faciès confie celle là
et ils se sont échappés des cats acquis
par ghosn et le français oui j'ai suivi
jeunes les voir non mais
mais c'est pas moi s'ils commencent à
ces propositions
c'est tout ce qui est le plus possible
le français vient de me gifler monsieur
bleus si vous à gifler parfaitement que
bravo pour votre travail et maintenant
ils sont déjà loin leur fête est finie
nous reprenons la haute direction chalon
car sélection du manque et
l'intelligence pour lyon est et ils vont
sûrement aller prendre le vapeur sur la
saône
il faut donc arriver avant deux à
l'embarcadère et vous oui moi trois
chevaux de postes non mais c'est vrai
j'ai écrit que je vais trouver
j'ai tellement envie toujours à pied si
le canada vous avez perdu ses deux
espions
vous les avez laissé filer alors que
vous savez ils vont au caire pour ruiner
nos accords avec l'egypte pour la
conquête de l'algérie brabo fontanier
c'est incompréhensible monsieur chatel
assure t il devait se rendre chez les
saint simoniens et ils n'y sont pas
allés et nous alors on est allé voir au
départ de la diligence pour lyon oui et
il n'était pas non plus et non et des
deux pays alors où sont ils
vous n'avez ils ont dû prendre la route
de châlons 2 pour mettez sur le vapeur
de lyon et c'est ça fait ça parce que
forcément il va aussi et bien messieurs
c'est tout simple vous allez partir pour
chalon chalon
je vais vous donner à cabriolet rapide à
barraute aussi vous profiterez de la
toile d'araignée que nous avons tissés
sur tout le royaume et parce que les
fils de cette toile d'araignée remis
entre tous les relais de poste qui sont
tenus d'enregistrer les noms de tous les
voyageurs ou finirait par retrouver ces
misérables gestion et quand je les aurai
retrouver je les arrête
non surtout pas non il faut remonter la
jungle est la journée suivez les pas à
pas jusqu'à la frontière et même plus
loin si cela s'avère utile
un jeu comme en plus loin d'eux mêmes
même à l'étranger
oui monsieur je vous donne carte blanche
et je protègerai votre mission
exceptionnelle
allez messieurs le service du roi
n'attend pas vive le roi mais respecte
mes respects monsieur le directeur
m
[Musique]
dit 'ok c'est la peur ont fait penser à
celui qui nous attend a su elle à nos
causses
mais un skimmer le maire n'est pas un
steam de rivières c'est une chose un peu
différente ouvert à lui j'espère mieux
et passagers pour mâcon lyon valence
avignon
[Musique]
e
frappeur
[Musique]
ça c'est des à 12 ans issus royale
accordée du courtier deviez accointances
notre connaissance le grand et le petit
ce sont bien des vacherins cette fois on
les tient et sur yon lille h prix le
grand et le détective qui nous a suivi
un autre ibère par yale le petit est
probablement son chef a bien la tête de
l'emploi
et jusqu'où vont ils continuer à nous
suivre comme ça au détective ça en tout
cas nous regarde
jusqu'où irons nous
[Musique]
voilà qu'arrivent les zones cette
vermine et d'intego nan je vous dis de
venir retardataires capitaine c'est trop
tard waris y ait pas de quartier la mer
et malicieux taylor nous aurons
peut-être le plaisir de vous revoir à
bombay ils sont d'abord allés film
[Musique]
attrapera le balto mâcon
je les regardais pas alors comme ça
comment vous avez participé à la
bataille de trafalgar
j'étais sur le redoute à hommage à celui
qui a tué personne le napoléon des mères
nous autres oui monsieur
et vous oh non non non je n'y étais pas
j'étais un peu trop trop jeune homme et
nargue la terrière vous n'auriez pas été
du même côté mille sabords en angliche
hay al qahtani notamment navals de sa
majesté et sa gestion entre collègues ça
s'arrose au top
la barre vous voyez ce que je vois je
peux
7e ils sont en train de crever leurs
chevaux pour ne cueillir à mâcon chien
mais ils nous font pas deux fois le truc
de la cata quand une solution ps venait
mais attention aux deux autres vacherin
suis des mois sans regarder à l'arrière
regardez
avec cette petite chose on pourrait tuer
deux oiseaux avec une seule pierre a
voulu dire faire d'une pierre deux coups
nous débarrasser de taylor et ces deux
lascars qui ne quitte pas surtout ne
regardez pas et burghardt non non j'ai
l'air de pas cher je crois qu'on peut y
aller alors on y va
[Musique]
ajouté
où
[Musique]
je fais j'ai dit de ne pas regarder
chaque cas rien à voir ne sont plus là
bas ils sont plus là comment soigner
guérir était là oui c'est ça et
maintenant il faut plus d'argent deux
semaines et les mois vous étiez glisser
sa vie sur la serbie en plus ce péno
terre regardez là on la trouvera jamais
si on va les retrouver et je vais vous
dire comment nous allons continuer
jusqu'à lyon avec ce vapeur à lyon je
m'installe au commandement de la
gendarmerie et je mobilise la
maréchaussée par ordre du roi ça fera
évidemment
ensuite la toile d'araignée calcul
d'areni enfin voyons pas serein celle de
cannelle et il nous fait de la sûreté ne
seront communiquées les noms des
voyageurs descendu dans tout les
auberges du royaume jusqu'aux frontières
suisses et italiennes impossible que les
deux espions et chats à ma toile et chef
vous êtes quand même une fameuses
araignées ou non
[Musique]
si nous continuons par la vallée du
rhône jusqu'à marseille nous sommes sûrs
de retomber sur nos jours oui mais
comment aller en italie par 15 gouttes
voilà ça y est bonaparte quoi bonaparte
soldats de l'armée d'italie je vous ai
trouvé maigre est presque nue je vais
vous conduire dans les plus fertiles
plein du monde radio creuser le chemin
de bonaparte par les alpes
ah oui je qu'on voit encore un éclair de
son génie ce chemin qu'il a fait prendre
à l'armée d'italie pour mieux surprendre
l'ennemi dans les plaines du pô rappelez
vous ces victoires foudroyante
l'audi marengo castillonnais mais où est
il passé exactement
tenez regardez mont noir par là par le
col du grand-saint-bernard
si nous prenons la même route nous
serons très vite à milan venise trieste
mais oui à trieste nous embarquons qu'un
pendant que les autres pays vont se
perdre à marseille et droit ce
alexandrie c'est sûr point là notre
chemin
je reconnais que votre odorat aura au
moins servi à quelque chose
merci pour lui mais pas ou la prendre
votre route du saint-bernard par genève
dax morales nous taylor n'est pas près
de nous retrouver à sa sûrement pas au
derby
pouvez vous nous faire préparer deux
choses oui messieurs où allez-vous à
genève par la route des rôles est bien
antoine selles de chevaux
whittom nous allons sûrement gagner
beaucoup de temps par ce chemin je vous
fais entièrement confiance mon chat bon
nous changeons chevaux à nantua ensuite
bellegarde et pour finir genève mme on
va aubergiste ben balles hautes
messieurs remercier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous verrons les voyageurs pour lyon
valence avignon vous pouvez embarquer
[Musique]
oh
m
vous les avez vus introuvable je doive
ses cachets pardon mon capitaine jérémy
onglets à beaurains
mais je ne le vois pas à al adli anglais
il a pris la poudre d'escampette entre
chalon et mâcon comeau qui m'a volé ma
marque
votre anglais vivent landre bon on
descendra à lyon
la route des indes gwec route passe par
alexandrie est pour selon alexandrie il
n'y a que deux ports d'embarquement ce
sont marseille et trieste où à caen se
dirige sur marseille où il a choisi
trieste et il fait route actuellement
vers la suisse et l'italie
ou alors on sépare oui moi je vais à
marseille et vous allez attristé par la
route des alpes ou bien c'est moi qui
retrouve walgren ou alors c'est beau et
on se rejoint ou alexandrie après avoir
causé vous ou moi
quelques petites sambia monsieur white
or au prix compris mais comment se
retrouve alexandre est bien en place et
nous devons y être dans un mois
et quand vous y serez vous irez tous les
matins devant la capitainerie du port
c'est là où nous nous retrouverons
impossible de manquer
ans
rien et vous vacherin rien non plus
alors elles sont pas passés par le
département du rhône
vous avez raison chaque fois comme
d'habitude on l'avait fiche des relais
auberge du département de l'inspecteur
c'est là les batman on partage encore un
petit enfant en fait tu sache écouter ça
vachement relais postaux trois faisans
messieurs waghorn et sassenage deux
chevaux de selle nantua bellegarde
genève rendez vous en suisse mais
gaillard en rodage rab en suisse je mets
bien longs mois on y mange est drôlement
bien
[Musique]
car
la masse et la suisse ne laisseront pas
avant demain
il fallait s'arrêter au prochain relais
alors c'est l'auberge de longerait 1
elle est tout près de la frontière oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
je
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment ils deviennent durs les
douaniers ces temps ci avec tout ce qui
vient de suisse oui j'ai eu peur quand
ils ont commencé à fouiller dans nos
sacs
tu sais avant qu'ils aient compris notre
petit trafic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regagner la livraison démontre das
effectué ce soir dans cette auberge vous
laisser entrer tout le monde le fait
mais vous le laisser sortir personne
dissimulé vous là bas et vous là bas
le dispositif est au point monsieur le
directeur parfait à ce qu'il veut ça de
près merci après oui vous êtes sûr de
votre information absolument monsieur le
directeur
les montres doivent être livrés ici ce
soir l'acheteur oui monsieur le
directeur
mais ce trafic dure depuis longtemps or
with you monsieur le directeur depuis
des mois et bien ce trafic entre genève
et la france va cesser le ministre des
finances estime à plus de 50 milles les
montres qui chaque année entre en france
frauduleusement
il faut donner un coup d'arrêt et je
suis venu pour ça
[Rires]
voici les gens aubergiste oui monsieur
sainte preuve oui je vous rappelle que
les bagages de tous les arrivants
devront être discrètement visiter nos
meilleurs bonsoir havas avez-vous de
chambre non il ne me reste plus qu'une
mais elle est à quatre lits diable
quatre lits ware a zappé du monde ça
peut-être vous demanderais jeu
d'accepter deux autres voyageurs s'il
s'en présente 4 sur wii comme vous
voudrez pour une de plus sur leur pause
et nous repartirons demain matin de
bonne heure lahrissi dieu merci
voilà mes seigneurs
voilà la chambre à quatre lits je vous
conseille c'est de l'ilac lapresa chine
et le feu chasse l'humidité des draps la
chambre est très calme elle donne sur
l'arrière de la maison
sa nature une cour ces messieurs se
feront ils oui dès que possible
nous voulons nous coucher ton pour les
métaux quand vous le voudriez messi
[Applaudissements]
bon ce formidable mais vous me semblez
souffrante
venez prière cheminée la chaleur vous
fera du bien nos coureurs souffre comme
vous voyez de la poitrine ce voyage là
tu veux donner moi la force d'aller
jusqu'au bout mais vous venez de loin de
la suisse monsieur et avant que le
seigneur me rappelle à lui j'ai désiré
novembre à besançon pour y être bénis
par année cherchons un abbé qui est un
vrai clair pour nous j'espère que vous
pourrez le gym est ma pauvre dame et il
ne me reste qu'une chambre à quatre lits
et je dois vous dire qu'il y a déjà deux
temps deux messieurs c'est tout ce que
j'ai à vous offrir
mais ce n'est pas possible hélas je n'ai
pas d'autres chambres
excusez moi mais dame madame vous avez
laissé tomber un dans attention les
douaniers sont là auberger oui nous
pouvons arriver
bien sûr monsieur installé mon char ici
merci bonsoir messieurs bonsoir materege
potage très bien
oui je suis désolé mais là mais je n'ai
rien d'autre que cette chambre à quatre
lits c'est très ennuyeux je sais que ce
n'est pas le courage de reprendre la
route un bien c'est à ma chérie eh bien
non alors nous allons peut-être prendre
cette chambre
mais à certaines conditions d'abord
qu'ils sont aimés ce gros ils sont très
bien
la vrille et acceptable ce centre je
reviens je vais les présentant monsieur
le directeur français d'un petit roman
l'air très bien je fouille aussi leurs
bagages plein ayant naturellement pour
moi tout le monde est suspect
martial saddier nages mon ami le
lieutenant thomas soan
nice to meet you bien sûr nous sommes
tout disposés à faire comme il vous
plaira
merci messieurs je suis mademoiselle
julie de balle à dieu et ma soeur madame
elvire de flétan coup merci messieurs
vous êtes les occupants de cette grande
chambre
oui la smala oui il faudrait que ces
messieurs acceptent de se plier à
quelques règles
mais ça va de soi même pour l'accord
passé entre les dames et les messieurs
le cas s'est déjà produit
me permettez vous de vous lire ce traité
qui sert habituellement dans cette
situation il a été établi pour la
première fois par un anglais monsieur
stern dans les 1700 66e voici le texte
bribon elle l'émission insiste pour que
les dames face la concession de prendre
les deux livrets à buffel qui sont les
plus chauds ségalant nous acceptons je
pense que la décence impose que ces
messieurs couche avec l'europe de
chambre oh désolé nous n'en avons pas
non non nos effets consiste en quelques
chemises et une culotte de soie noire je
crois que nous pouvons accepter la
qualité soit noir soit messieurs c'est
un geste de confiance nous y sommes très
sensibles secundo il est exigé est
stipulé par ces dames qu'une fois la
chandelle éteintes les messieurs ne
diront plus un seul mot de toute la nuit
peut toutefois les prières dites par les
messieurs ne seront pas considérés comme
une infraction au traité
wright vous pouvez être assurés de notre
bonne tenue merci messieurs et ces dames
d'idron elle pour à peine menton nous
mettre à l'aise le shérif nous
redescendons la suite
voilà la france est vraiment remarquable
peur on y vit des aventures improvisé à
ça
comment vous trouvez la bonne pas mal
pas mal mais celle qui tous est encore
plus jolie alors je prendrai brune
alors tout est parfait brewerton voulez
vous prendre place
bonsoir aubergiste bonsoir on saigne
être mais là où qu'est ce que je vais
vous servir très peu de choses peut-être
un petit potage de légumes vos petites
tranches de jambon
oui ce sera très bien comme ça vient
[Musique]
on
ah oui
et la jolie coup de fourchette la
mourante
ouais bon appétit blanc et ensuite mais
la main peu de pot-au-feu ou de la
fricassée de dindonneau j'aime bien peu
de pot-au-feu pour l'afrique assez
étonnés nous là au chaud nous
l'apprendrons empreinte bien mais
l'homme est ce que les malades anglais
manche autant que les malades français
oui mais seulement quand elle sent guère
une toile que personne ne sorte
monsieur le directeur voilà ils sont
pris ou avez vous joué cela agents
assermentés du roi de france
j'ai l'honneur de déclarer que j'ai
découvert des articles manifestement de
contrebande dans les bagages de ces
messieurs watts cause et vous prétendre
allons monsieur ne fait pas lino ce
monsieur c'est une machination
si ce coffret était dans nos bagages
c'est conduire à me suis dit ce sont
sans doute ces deux pauvres femmes qui
ont mis ce coffret renfermant 30 mille
francs de montres en or dans vos 5 nous
le dise rien cela suffit messieurs
dès demain nous instruire on votre
affaire conduirait dans leur chambre
un homme devant leur porte l'autre dans
la cour ma longue vie à - mesdames que
vous pensiez ne pas pouvoir cohabiter
avec ces individus position la
contrebande du pas un péché mortel
[Musique]